alright it looks like I'm online on
Facebook hello everyone at Facebook
sorry I'm running a little bit late if
you asked I'll tell you about my morning
and it looks like we're online on
YouTube alright so this is good as you
could imagine this has been an
interesting improvisational situation
for all of us so my apologies for
getting started a little late this
morning but this is what our our fourth
live stream that we're doing and you
know the whole goal of this is we have
all these resources at Khan Academy that
we've been building over the last ten
actually 11 12 years and we could have
never foreseen this type of a situation
the Khan Academy we've always imagined
that the ideal use case being in being
used in physical classroom so students
can learn at their own time and pace
give teachers information on where
students are and be able to do more
focused interventions for your class
time for other things and also support
students who might not have had
traditional schooling or if you're in
some part of the world that doesn't have
that we would have never seen this
school closure situation we're in
but it's Khan Academy is eerily
well-suited to at least help us work on
this because obviously we have things
from Khan Academy kids for early
learners for math reading writing
social-emotional learning and then you
get into the core of Khan Academy in
math for sure all the way through from
middle school high school elementary
school through college English Language
Arts SAT practice we have the sciences
especially at the high school level ap
level and also several humanities
American history cetera and the purpose
of this livestream is to give a little
bit more connectedness to that some
people are starting to call this kind of
a homeroom for us and like homeroom is
in school it's the time to talk about
anything a time whatever announcements
need to be made etc and also just got a
little bit of motivation a little bit of
energy for the day whether you're a
teacher you're a parent or a student
just a room this is just a reminder that
we're all going through this together
and we're all gonna figure it out
together and so you know I encourage
anyone I start asking questions on
whether you're watching on Facebook or
YouTube on the streams I have team
members who are looking at those
questions we're going to be surfacing
them up on my on my
tablet right over here and so I'll know
who to answer questions for you know
just a couple of updates on our side we
are seeing and I guess this isn't super
surprising but unusual traffic on Khan
Academy what I heard from our team is a
Monday we saw 50% a larger than expected
usage and then yesterday 80% and we were
seeing kind of you know 10x the number
of teacher and student and parent
registration so that's great that it
sounds like a lot of people are
realizing that this is a resource that
they can turn to it's free it's
accessible and hopefully as we go
through this this crisis folks become
more comfortable with using it and I
think there's some ideas we can talk
about upon and complement it I do want
to say thank you to Bank of America for
those of you don't know Khan Academy we
are not-for-profit that means no one
owns Khan Academy we are not a company I
don't own Khan Academy you own as much
of Khan Academy as I do and we're funded
through philanthropy and we love that
we're able to serve everyone right now
as we as we have this crisis but our
server costs are through the roof
we're having demand more folks to be
able to do things like webinars we had a
very large parent webinar that had a
thousand parents on it last night and
and and so it's really valuable that
Bank for America stepped up you could do
a Google search and read about that
press release but they stepped up to
really support this you can almost call
it a relief effort that we're trying to
up our game at Khan Academy to make sure
everyone feels connected and supported
and expect to see more from us and our
partners like like Bank of America so
thank you to Bank of America for that
but let me get to let me get to some of
the questions here so the first question
is how do I figure out what my child
should be learning so there's a couple
of ways to answer that obviously as a
parent you might know what grade your
students in and you might say okay my
students are the fifth grader
that might be an indication that fifth
grade on Khan Academy might be a really
good place to start I will put a little
asterisk there a little bit of a caveat
what we found even when working with
traditional schools is the reason why a
lot of kids have trouble this is
especially true in math but it's also
true in things like reading and writing
but especially in math they might have
trouble in fifth sixth seventh grade
math it's not because they're not bright
it's not because the subject matter is
difficult it's because as they went
through their academic foundations they
had some gaps they might have been in
third grade when they were learning
multiplication tables they just didn't
learn their 7 times tables well and they
got to see on a test and then they just
moved on to the next thing and so when
they see have to multiply something by
seven and sixth grade they just have to
spend a little bit too much cognitive
load or their decimals in fifth grade
our gap and so when they see a decimal
in seventh grade it's a gap so one thing
we've seen teachers do to great effect
there's an amazing teacher Tim
Vandenberg was talking to two days ago
he was telling me how with his sixth
graders he starts them all on
kindergarten on Khan Academy and if you
know the material the students can go
through each course quite quickly we
have things like course challenges unit
tests mastery challenges that can
accelerate students through it that
helps them build some momentum build
some confidence get familiarity with the
platform and then it mentors that they
don't have any gaps so he has his
students do early learning and then do
the arithmetic of courses on Khan
Academy and the 3rd grade courses he
used those as the foundational ones and
simultaneously work on the grade-level
course on Khan Academy if your student
has for the most part been proficient in
math then I would go straight to the
grade-level course on Khan Academy
if since we're already well into the
year I would have your child and if your
student I would have you take the course
challenge and the course challenge will
sample every unit and if you take the
course challenge and you get an 80 or 90
percent on it keep taking the course
challenge and try to get higher and
higher scores until you have mastery in
the course but if you see there's some
gaps that you're consistently not
getting right then those skills you can
look at those units that they come from
and then you can ensure that you get
mastery in those units and so that's a
way that we're you know we're 3/4 or 80%
through the year that you can quickly
know what you know and what you don't
know and where you need to actually fill
in your gaps so that's my personal view
of the quickest way to figure out what
we're where might be the right zone for
you and the same thing is true at the
high school level you know even high
school students doesn't hurt starting a
little bit behind you have more time now
and make sure you fill in those gaps and
things like our SAT practice that we do
with the College Board that adapts to
you so if you start getting a question
a certain skill wrong it will give you
slightly easier ones or than slightly
harder ones if you get them right so
that's my my best advice there you know
some people have been asking for just
general tips and I was on some of the
morning shows today and you know what I
say is make sure you have some structure
today as we get more days into the
social distancing it's very tempting to
stay in your pajamas and kind of you
know we're trying to work from bed with
the TV running and all that that's not
going to be good and it's not good even
for your own mental health it's good to
have a pattern wake up in the morning
just like you would have done for school
have your breakfast get ready have you
even heard about some people pretending
like they're on a bus for some period I
guess that's a maybe a form of
meditation and then break into the
schedule and we had Khan Academy we've
released some schedules for school
closures and it's four different
schedules four different age groups that
have different amounts breaks and things
like that in them but use those you
could use those just as they are or you
can modify them to meet your needs but
if you have that schedule then that also
gives you a clearer sense and say if I
get all this done by one o'clock in the
afternoon or two o'clock I can then
relax I can then go do other things
pursue my passions work on other hobbies
ideally you have a place in the house
that is nice and clean of free of
clutter where you just associate that
with work and that just that that
spatial Association I think will help
your help your productivity all right so
we have Sayid mo he'll Rosales asked
will Khan Academy always be free simple
answer is yes you know our mission
statement is free world-class education
for anyone anywhere the whole idea about
being a not-for-profit there's nothing
wrong with for-profit companies most of
my career I'd worked at some form of a
for-profit or other but a for-profit
company at the end of the day their
bottom line literally is you know
maximizing shareholder value or income
or things like that nothing wrong with
that that's how capitalism works but a
not-for-profit its bottom line is its
mission and our mission is free
world-class education for anyone
anywhere and the reason why we set it up
as a not-for-profit you know twelve
years ago I could have never foreseen
this scenario is because there's certain
parts of our market economy where
market forces alone might not work
properly or if they did work properly it
might not lead to the types of outcomes
we want and you know I frankly I think
education and healthcare are the two
areas where you you don't want someone's
access to it to be gated by their
ability to pay or you know what the
parents do for a living or that you know
things like that and so that's why kind
of kind of me is free and will always be
free and it's not and it's not for
profit it's primarily funded through
philanthropic donations so tada
Bevell says frustrating trying to help
my college engineering some of this
internet issues he also needs tutoring
in calculus too and physics any help so
depends what the internet issues are I
don't have good advice for if there's
connectivity issues maybe the local
carrier whoever might might be able to
help with some of that but if he's
taking calculus to in physics we can
help there Khan Academy has a full
depending on which college you go to
first two semesters or three semesters
of college calculus not just videos we
have exercises you get as much practice
as you need so I really encourage your
son to get on that make sure he same
advice I have for the younger students
take the course challenge understand
what he knows and doesn't know
that he can focus on the units that he
he has some gaps in and then if he's
able to get to say ninety percent
mastery on our on our college calculus
or our Calculus BC which is AP but still
a first-year college course I think
he'll do great we have the same thing in
first year physics he could use our AP
physics which is really college physics
that I hopefully will will help him so
let's see Alistair OVA kill Ola asks how
do I motivate my little brother to study
during the quarantine he really doesn't
want to do anything and Alicia rova i I
empathize with you
I know I have three kids at home and the
old or two I have to give them a lot of
credit 11 and and eight years old they
are really productive I think even more
productive than me their schools doing a
you know they're getting a list of stuff
to do every day they're there they're
connecting on Hangouts with with their
teachers at appropriate times so they're
fine but my five-year-old I've been
having a lot of difficulty I'm
motivating him I think he's just getting
used to the circumstances that we're all
finding ourselves in we had a good tip
from a homeschooling parent a couple of
days ago on
this livestream where she said you just
have to stick with it at first it's hard
everyone's getting used to the same
patterns but it's just about sticking
with it maintaining a pattern having
consistency you know for very young kids
I hope none of y'all art well I hope you
are listening but my technique with my
five-year-old sometimes the direct
course of action is not the ones work on
this he will resist but if you say hey
that was really amazing how many points
you got yesterday then you know kind of
strokes his ego a little bit he gets a
little little excited about that or if
you say hey tell me about that song you
really like and then while while he
tells you about the song I'd kind of
open up the work he needs to do it and
driving or whatever else so no that's
that's one possibility but I think you
know this is one of those times don't
beat up yourself it's really impressive
as a sibling you're trying to help your
sibling but you know don't put too much
pressure on yourself do what you can
keep some consistency and what what the
homeschooling parents are telling us is
that oh it's still the first week for
most of us and so you know it's okay we
can we can give all of ourselves a break
and you know and this is the other thing
we're gonna probably form some habits
over the next month or two as the
schools are closed and it sounds like it
in many places they will be close to the
end of the school year we're hearing
that in California but though we have
the whole summer to continue learning to
you know catch up if we need to fill in
gaps and then continue learning so as
long as people are able to ramp into the
summer and keep learning during the
summer I'm not worried that they're
going to be able to do just fine when
schools reopen all right
so someone says how will Khan Academy
get me into places like Stanford
University I understand oh I understand
a guy who was locked up for 15 years
user resources and got into Stanford
okay so Adam Adam bukhari asked that
question so I'll first give my
disclaimer where you go to college
Justin does not define you as a human
being I think too many times in our
society and a lot of the signals you get
in high school and and when you're young
or your friends are like you're defined
but you know you try it you're trying to
find your identity and you might be
defined by your test scores or where you
go to college etc etc and you your life
is far more than that these test scores
are where you go to college now for
those of you who are you know you
there's nothing wrong with wanting to go
to a highly selective University I would
just say just don't be attached to it as
Buddha says the course of all the the
source of all suffering is it you should
always try your best and it's great to
be able to find a college that will
challenge you that will put you around
other people that will make you make you
better my best advice and I tell this
you know we have a Lab School downstairs
and I tell this to the students about
your age is make sure you really master
material don't try to you know be do
everything master the core for sure you
know the the mathematics the science is
the writing the humanities but make sure
you have time and space for your
passions you know you see a lot of
students who they think they have to do
everything in order to impress other
people and in some ways the other people
will say that person is just trying to
do everything to impress me who are they
really
and we I've talked to a lot of
admissions officers we have some on our
advisory board here at Khan Academy and
they all tell us we just want to see
authenticity for sure they need to see
kids who they feel confident will be
able to handle the academic rigor of
their campus but they just want to see
authenticity they want to see curiosity
they want to see creativity and so I
think find your passions you have you
know glass-half-full the school closures
you might have a little more time now
this is a great time to explore your
passions find solutions for people in
your neighborhood there's all sorts of
people who need help right now do it
authentically don't do it just to get
into college say hey there might be
senior citizens who can't go to the
grocery store maybe I can drop off the
groceries out there at their porch maybe
I can turn into a thing me and my
friends can volunteer to do that if you
do it authentically then when it's time
to apply to college and if you're
academically prepared you've given it
your best shot and so that's that's my
best advice you know the example you
gave Jason who was for those of you who
don't know the story this was a young
man when he was in his teens he got
arrested for selling marijuana
he got thirty years in prison in
Illinois while in prison his mother gave
him transcripts of Khan Academy videos
so he constructs learned they'd had no
access to the Internet he had his
sentence shortened to 15 years so he
gets out in his early 30s and then he
gets on Khan Academy for real at the
local library uses our official SAT
practice and he's able to kind of catch
up and he initially said his local
music college but he decides that he
wants to apply to Stanford and he was
able to transfer and I met him and
that's how I even know the story so
there's some I don't say that is the way
that you know he could have Stanford but
I'm saying that as a way that I think
anyone if you apply yourself you put
your best foot forward and you're
authentic about it you know I would say
what's really powerful about Jason is
stories how authentic he is and how much
he owns his own history and I think
that's really powerful and people would
be impressed by that let's see I'll be
the shake says do you have any science
classes for middle school on Khan
Academy so obviously that is actually a
gap that we have officially we don't
have middle school science per se with
that said what I will tell you is I
think the high school biology is
completely doable by a mythical middle
school student the math prerequisites
you would have already seen in middle
school
things like negative numbers and
decimals and exponents and things like
that and so and especially because high
school biology super interesting right
now because you'll learn about viruses
and DNA and RNA and you know that's very
relevant to the world we're at so I
would recommend high school students to
work on the high school sorry middle
school students to work on the high
school biology on Khan Academy I think
that could keep you busy and you'll
learn a lot and that's just a useful
useful skill for life alright so so
lethal hipster distrusting name says hi
Khan how long have you been teaching
well depends how you define teaching you
know I I've taught in various formal and
informal settings over over many years
if I were to go really far back the
first time that I realized that I
enjoyed tutoring or teaching was in high
school it might not surprise people but
I was the president of the math club I
assure you it was cooler than you might
imagine and as part of that we had we
used to tutor a lot of our we stitute we
had free tutoring for everyone at our
school and I saw over and over again
that students by my friends who thought
they weren't good at math if they just
had a little bit of attention a little
bit of being able to fill in their gaps
then all of a sudden were like wait this
isn't so bad and and then they were they
were off to the races and so that's what
first stuck in my head of the reason why
people are held back isn't because of
their ability it's because of these gaps
and they just need a little bit of
civilization so to speak to fill in
those gaps then in college I I did some
actually IT I taught at the there's a
local school district in Brookline
Massachusetts and they had lost funding
for some of their classes and so they
were looking for volunteer teachers so
when I was in college it was actually
myself and my roommate named Jonathan
and Sinha and he was actually the first
president of Khan Academy we used to go
volunteer teach at Brookline devotion
school this was in Brookline
Massachusetts in middle school students
and then later in college I actually was
doing some test flight test prep stuff
for for folks like Princeton Review and
then I hear to go completely different I
wanted to attack etc Center but I was
always fascinated by this whole teaching
side and so in my cousins in 2004 needed
help I was like hey can I tutor you
because I just love it's just fun to be
able to connect with people I love the
subject matter and then that's kind of
how I got started on this this Khan
Academy adventure that was about 16
years ago yesterday someone commented
about how old I look and so that's why
someone is asking and he says hey Sal's
817 am here and I'm about to live with
schedules that you plans thank you so
much Andy great news and yeah my apology
I know these live students conflict with
the same schedules that we publish and
it's hard because those schedules are
whatever time zone you're on and
obviously this live stream is happening
at different times depending on what
time zone you are in but I'm glad you're
using the schedules and we are going to
look for more ways to support those
schedules in the continued support si
says how can I learn personal finance at
Khan Academy you could literally look at
our menus there's a course menu when you
go to the top left and Finance and
personal finance our sections on Khan
Academy those don't have the exercises
the way that math and other subjects do
but there's a lot of videos there and I
think if you look at those videos and
especially if if I'm working through a
problem you pause and you try to do it
on your own you'll be surprised how much
personal finance you might learn and I'm
happy to answer actually any personal
finance questions if anyone has any and
I know this is a time that might be
stressing folks finances so I'm or maybe
they're having questions about the stock
market and my you know my old life I
used to be an investment analyst so I
don't mind entering into questions about
that
okay so Christine pretty will you be
adding more courses etc at school stay
closed for a longer time a great
question Christine you know we we're
looking to do anything and and
everything necessary to be able to
support folks through this school
closure situation it looks like they
will be closed and you know in many
places through the end of the year we're
talking you know everything we do is
feeln topically funded so you know we
talked earlier about the the gap we have
in middle school science I would love
nothing more than to be able to create
some middle school science content on
Khan Academy we need to find
philanthropists small and large
philanthropists every donation counts so
that we can start hiring up a team of
folks who can start helping build that
content you know a lot of time I get
disproportionate credit for Khan Academy
cuz I make a lot of the videos and you
know I'm kind of the mascot for a better
force I'm not so pleasant of a mascot
but there's a lot of people behind the
scenes we have over 200 employees who
have salaries that we need to be able to
pay so that they can do their work most
of these people have taken salary cuts
from what they could be doing in the
for-profit sector because they're so
passionate about this mission and on the
content side I have a ton of support
from people oftentimes with PhDs in the
subject who are curating what the what
the sequence should be how we cover the
standards writing these thousands of
items that we have to write per course
getting it vetted with outside third
party so there's a lot of work that goes
on behind the scenes for those courses
but I hope that we can add more and more
courses especially if it looks like this
this this crisis continues for you know
beyond what we're thinking right now so
let's see high school seniors are
stressed about school closures no
problem no graduation ceremony what
advice do you have for them so I'm I'm I
don't know how all of this is going to
play out and you know there's some part
of it that's not so great that you're
you you might miss out on some of these
whatever you want to call them rites of
rites of passage what I would say to you
is you and your generation especially
those of you who are high school juniors
and seniors right now this is going to
define your generation you know when
you're my age y'all are gonna sit around
the table and reminisce
about 2022 remember that remember
coronavirus remember what was special
about our generation and I think that
actually will in many ways form deeper
bonds then you know all of the other
things that you might have done in the
past and I think there's ways that you
can still have those experiences let's
say you graduate let's say we're still
in this in this quarantine or stay at
home policy and so you're not able to
get those formal ceremonies maybe they
can happen in the fall once ought we
surface from this or at a later date and
that that could be fun too you know I'm
supposed to be involved with a few
graduations earlier this summer and yeah
I'm assuming they might not happen but
the I hope they eventually happen so
that those students can get their proper
congratulations for what they've done so
so it'll all be it'll all be good at the
end so I wouldn't worry about it too
much take care of yourself more than
anything and I think it'll all all work
out so let's see other questions here
Lisa Moore says so homeschooling parent
here can confirm it it does get better
the routine becomes normal important to
keep a routine of sorts and you're right
ditch the PJ 24/7 habit it's harder to
break later on okay so reinforcement
change out of your pajamas patience and
perception know yourself know your kid
great advice
Lisa thank you for that
you know I just got news from I just got
a news from from our team here that you
know our partners make for America whoo
you know we had that earlier question
about financial literacy they were the
ones that have funded that financial
literacy work in career work we have on
Khan Academy over the last seven years
in especially for many of y'all who are
teenagers or in your early 20s we have a
ton of content not just on financial
literacy but different career paths and
how to navigate them and and the pros
and cons and and and the financial
stresses or benefits of different
careers and so the bank has been
instrumental in funding all of that over
the last seven years and as I mentioned
they have been the first company to step
up over literally over the weekend when
they realized that we needed support as
a non-profit they step up and it looks
like they just announced a hundred
million dollars of support to nonprofits
worldwide so that's a huge deal you know
I know the folks at the bank for a while
folks like and felucca and Meredith
Michelle and you know I've just been
inspired by their willingness to step up
and help the world as just as human
beings and I think that is just
representative of the whole of the whole
Bank
let's see any other questions so there's
more questions coming in we're close to
time maybe I could do one one one more
question but well you know I'll just
finish up with a standard message this
is a time that is challenging for all of
us but you know the point of this live
stream is to remind all of us that were
in this together as I've said in
previous live streams this is actually
something that I really enjoy connecting
with all of y'all because I've been
penned up in my house for or this week
and so I think it's as all of us are
navigating this as long as we stay
connected as long as we keep learning
and as long as we recognize that this is
all gonna this is all going to sort
itself out over time it's going to be a
blip in our life it's going to be make
for great stories to tell our children
and our grandchildren how we all stepped
up and dealt with this and supported
each other in this together I'll also
just give a public-health announcement I
really do encourage people to take the
social distance seriously
posted a video over the weekend and I
think you do a search for like Khan
Academy and Co vid or something like
that it'll tell you how you know these
things grow and the reported cases are
probably are for sure understanding the
actual cases out there because not
everyone's tested not everyone has had
symptoms and so you might be carrying it
and you might be lucky and not have so
much symptoms especially if you're young
but if you want to protect your parents
and your grandparents do your best to
keep as social distance that's the best
way that this looks the sooner that
everyone does that the quicker that we
will get through this and that the lower
chance we have of overwhelming our
healthcare system so thank you everyone
it's it's a real treat to be able to do
this with you thanks for joining in and
you know get on Khan Academy and learn
and use the schedules and tell everyone
about it as well I think there's still a
lot of parents and students who are
feeling a little lost and and so the
more that